knee pull
so uh first you have to float it
so first elongate up
then try to stay as high as you can
and that's what comes forward
so out my knees are going to go up my
pelvis is going to go up
and then they're going to come forward
you're doing two moves one
two
okay let's go okay so
remember the aspects of it so it's the
my hips over his hips
that is the guard part keeping him back
he can't come forward
then my knees
my inner knees you want to try to be on
the back hemisphere
the back hemisphere so there's a line on
his side
i don't want my knees on that line or
worse in front of the line even if my
legs are long enough
if your legs are long enough take
advantage of it
and then bring the third aspect the
bottom legs
are on him wait wait on him
so not out here okay
so up
in and then weight is here
so he's going to try to get up and i'm
just leaving that weight there
it's not that he can't get up he can get
up but there's
pressure on the upper part of his spine
his legs are down not him
okay
so the first ground vector he has to
deal with
is this front part of my legs
okay so uh he does not bring me up
and he just tries to bring me forward i
can just ground that
part of his body so he has to first
float me up that will go slow
okay goes up and so i'm here
he changed the relationship and now he
has to feel that problem
and he has to get me over that so he
goes
boom good okay and now
he has to be cognizant
that this is not too low because i can
move
up and i'm right back or i started okay
so he has to feel give me the final
position
okay he has to be wary that i'm not
coming inside of
this thing at the same time
i move under under this thing i'll get
right back where i want to be
okay so he's gonna float
then he you should feel my knees i go
over it
good and then he's gotta keep me down as
high as possible
so let's scoot this lower because if
it's low
it's easy just to reset okay
so again elongate over the knee
boom and then down so for me this is too
low
there you go you got to really try to
get to the top part of my spine
okay because as he goes
boom boom and he's low uh
it's it's easy for me to move inside of
the same thing that i was reversing
okay and it should not be so easy so
let's say
difference in torsos leg length
all that kind of stuff okay i still
gonna float
then over the knees and if i have to
i'll climb again i gotta be as high as
possible
and not down here where it's comfortable
so feel how you can
[Music]
it yes so when i come
up boom try to be here as high as
possible
so he goes it's hard for him
to s out of that okay
all right let's try all right so you
have to be sensitive to
uh be able to determine what are the
structures of his
equilibrium okay and then otherwise how
do i just deconstruct them
um usually what the beginner does is
they just deconstruct
by the application of the form which
kind of
technically pre-deconstructed what
they're doing but you'll find when you
go to giwaza
it doesn't really work that way the dude
moved a little bit things are a little
bit off so you always have to be able to
adapt the form
in order to adapt the form you have to
be able to tell what is constructing
this equilibrium
so that you can deconstruct it so we'll
scoot back
and he's here and we're gonna look at
that foot
okay so uh right now he's
he's balancing between my my grip and
that foot
okay so a lot of you will just
kind of like turn like this you see
so you're going and you turn the guy
but now we're in gus then he can
he'll get out of it if he wants
so once you uh pin the foot do you feel
like this
okay so he's he's gonna try to uh walk
on that
foot it's very hard to do but when you
do that momentum throws
he's actually it's him it's him
that decided not to move his foot and so
when you go to g was that he gets his
decision back
do you understand so there has to be a
pin on the on the foot
can't be here you can keep walking and
you can you can even if i go low if
there's no pin on on the foot it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter
and it doesn't matter if i go fast
that that foot has woo has to be pinned
cannot be movable so
i pin the foot and then my next energy
has to go past that so
i don't go uh just here
it's got to go past
and the best way of going past is it at
a vector
uh different from his forward progress
so i don't go this way
but
[Music]
so you deal with that all the time
he's down
and that's what he's dealing with here
so
as he goes up we're gonna go slow
then he should feel that foot and he'll
feel when i get on the
other side of that articulation
do you know what i mean so he i go up
i'm still
on this side of that fulcrum
but there's going to be a time when my
center of gravity is on the
other side of that fold
so we're going to now incorporate the
arm drop
and at this point in every point where
my line of gravity is on
that side of my front knee
he's not pulling he's just checking
he's getting ready so he's going to feel
and when he feels me coming over
that's when he adds the arm drag to the
knee pull
though
to pull the arm with my weight on the
other side
is a yang yang clash
and it's mechanically inferior so
he goes let's say he does the thing and
he goes to pull the arm he's gonna find
that's
really heavy and i can get a lot of
resistance in there
because i can continue to ground vector
off of that
front part of my leg so he has to get my
line of gravity going forward
you can even you can take you want to
keep any slack out
yet you're just not pulling on it
so if i'm letting you move it you move
it but you don't
pull me into that front post
he goes you'll feel it that's when he
goes
so he's doing the first drill up float
pump pull and it's more of a push really
when you think about it
let's go okay so he's
uh dealing with all this we're going to
add the arm direct
boom and his goal here is to get my head
as low as possible so he doesn't want me
here
low as possible with a certain point
this
is going to pass into his grips are
going to pass into a hidden phase
and so he has to be able to transfer
over
to a new grid okay what i mean by that
is as he goes right now he's in the
young phase it's very hard for me to
pull this
back okay but as he goes it starts to go
yin
again and i can pull my hand back
okay so he has to transfer over
and he's going to go into that side
scissor okay
and so it's the same concept as he's
trying to be on the top
the highest part or the longest part of
my spine as a lever
he goes and he's going to move
over let me fix you and try to get this
knee higher up my back
to stop me from coming up like i just
did
he can go to a lap pool too he goes
we'll pop and he goes over and but it's
about weight
on the upper part of my bottom so shift
all this down
lower your hand down it's just very easy
for me to reverse them
it's not enough just to get that side
scissor so
elongate feel the sp the knee
then the push as low as possible
and then up high high up on the spine
not down low on his waist
up here okay because what i want
is to take advantage of the back
exposure so
look at his head and get your head
higher than his that's going to make the
back taking
advantage of the back exposure much
easier
so here down
down here
up pass boom
up boom here
get your bottom hip back past
the bottom apex so don't have it here
because he can roll me over
my bottom hip is gonna turn under and
that's what brings this knee up higher
oh above his head
weight down down down
okay let's go so as i get
there and i'm coming up
you're going to when it when you turn
this bottom hip
more positive it's harder for him to
roll me over because
my spine is turned over
or my hips are turned in a positive
angle to my spine
so when i'm here like this he can just
reverse the whole thing
but when i'm here like this and i bring
more weight up here
and he tries to roll me over i can
cause myself to be in more one piece
and not be so rollable
that angle that i take on the bottom hip
is also going to be reinforced by this
hand
so when i seek my elbow to get my head
over
i don't want it over here because this
is more rollable over
i want it where it's going to brace my
other efforts okay but be cognizant that
the more space you create
the more maneuverability he has so
this for example would be a great
reinforcement to the bottom hip but
it's going to take away from my efforts
so you got to find that place where
it's going to work okay and then
immediately i'm going to add more weight
to his body
by using his back to focus my hips
off the ground so not my hand
but my leg here
the only reason my hand gets extended my
arm
is that i want to keep my head above his
head
so if i could keep my head above his
without having to extend my arm i might
do that
but definitely i'm not going to go like
this
i'm going to take this weight and drive
it down into him
so don't take that weight off when you
come to your hand
so it goes one and then my hand and she
should feel
more weight when i come to that hand not
less
weight because i'm back over here so
more weight
under his head
still working with weight on the distal
end of his spine
up keep the hand from posting
just pin it wait on his head
take him into the front
inward kazushi okay let's go
the skill review again i'm going to try
the knee pull and the arm drag
and it's even though i'm on the positive
side of his
line of gravity and his base of support
people are strong
so they pull they can pull it in
okay so we're going to use that for the
triangle opening
so boom he pulls
i'm going to shove it in
and then come on top of the trapezius
but in order to do that i have to keep
this in place and that's what i use
to fulfill my hips up
so we'll go slow so you can see i'm
trying it
i'll feel it i go with the energy keep
this
in place use that to lift my hips
back of my knee is on the trapezius
heel comes down and i'm applying the
same concept of b
on the distal end of his spine so you
see
that i still have the same knee pulling
action okay i'm not down here
or up here pulling him in
knee pulling he fights it boom over the
top i go
back on the distal end okay
here let's get it there's not there's
not two arcs
so uh as as i'm on the outside i can go
on the
inside okay as as i'm on the
inside i can go to the outside so we're
just going to play around
and you'll see that i can change
positions going from one
one hand inside out
all the time
so i'm doing the same thing here
so i'm going to grab like this
you pull he goes to shove the arm back
and i come around it so i can shove that
into him
it's not going to be this hand that hand
is chasing it
this hand keeps the adhesion
wow
okay let's go all right
so boom hop
he goes feeling it
up okay
this arm i gotta move to the other side
so
i'm going to extend him and push it
to the other side
then i'm going to replace this leg
with my hand so i still have
the distal end of his spine being
weighted down and he's in a circle guard
still then i'm going to move myself
over to get the bottom leg
off of his back so i move myself over
and you can do whatever you need to to
get that to go
then over swing out pull down
hips up
warm hop
secure move this hand out of the way
it's in different places
all the time okay it does it doesn't
matter
come around hips up move it out of the
way
tuck it in place okay
hand then off get his back
outside out of the grip if you have to
you can adjust
afterwards okay